hosts a monthly winemakers table dinner
where guests can enjoy greek wines
paired with a five course meal and it's
all happening at the venetian here to
tell us all about it is ronnie bouya
cleo
did i get it yes you nailed it
thanks for being here absolutely yeah
you and i go way back we've done a bunch
of interviews over the years and the
last time i saw you was right before the
world shut down and we were talking all
about wine and we never got to
experience it so now we get to
experience it
i'm so excited about this anything
having to do with wine first off you
know sign me up but you are the expert
tell us all about this special dinner
that's happening so
thank you for the nice words but uh yeah
for uh each month here at milos we do a
special winemakers table where it
explores the different wines of greece
and highlights a different theme each
month so it's a five course tasting menu
for ninety four dollars a person and
includes five wine pairings and uh for
july i'm super excited where you have a
really fun fourth of july independence
day type of theme where we're putting
american wines against the greek wines
from the same grape variety so you get
to taste the difference in the kind of
wine making philosophy of the greek
wines versus the american and the
difference in the climate and altitude
and all that stuff so is there a big
difference between the two when it comes
to the americans versus the greek wines
i think definitely i mean uh just the
soil being different and you know of
course in greece you have the
mediterranean sea influencing all the
different wines so it's really you know
fascinating being able to taste a
sauvignon blanc from sonoma right next
to a sauvignon blanc from the north of
greece and you really you know same
grape but totally different expressions
well and i've had the chance to
experience one of these dinners before
and i have to say i was so full after
but it was so delicious and the wines
just you don't realize how perfectly
things can really pair together that's
why we turn to the experts like you
synergy for sure yeah and what i love
about milos it's so beautiful in there
it's a great place just for any time of
day
oh absolutely i mean you know beautiful
white marble everywhere really you know
just a
clean food excellent wine so it's really
a lovely dinner well you uh you had me
at wine but the food sounds great too so
ronnie thank you so much you are the
expert and you can be sure to go over to
the venetian meals is great anytime but
especially for this wine table dinner so
thank you for being here always great to
see you always great seeing you all
right
need help summer
oh sorry i'm talking over here rocky
there